users expect more and more from their
applications than ever before to meet
these expectations the developer
capabilities and IBM cloud enable your
team to use one platform to produce
deliver run and manage apps with IBM
cloud you have all the necessary
capabilities needed to start building
apps in minutes
IBM cloud developer tools create a
high-performing foundation the
developers need to get up and running we
offer two main tools for development IBM
cloud web console and IBM cloud
command-line interface to better
understand how our experience can help
you let's take a look at these elements
in more detail our developer portals
have an array of features like use case
specific starter kits production ready
starter apps and the ability to create
DevOps tool chains with just a few
clicks
looking to comprise code data services
and tool chains in a matter of minutes
we've got you covered with starter kits
we want your experience to be easy to
use and customizable you are in control
if a starter kit requires specific
resources no problem with auto
provisioned resources IBM cloud
automatically creates instances for
those resources when you create your app
access starter kits from the developer
portal or command line interface for
instructions that are relevant to your
focus area and order flow you can create
simple blank apps directly or create
more complex apps by using our starter
kits if you choose to create blank apps
without the help of a starter kit our
newly released feature allows you to do
so from the IBM cloud dashboard without
visiting a portal when you create an app
directly or with the help from a starter
kit it contains portable code portable
code contains cloud enablement code for
multiple cloud environments you can then
produce code in four foundational areas
code that follows best practices for a
given language code that enables the app
to run on the cloud code that is
initialized to connect to cloud services
and codes specific to a use case as a
developer you now can either generate
your code through our provided tools or
you can
bring your own code and deploy it to IBM
cloud the DevOps tool chain comprises
procedures and tools for accessing
developing deploying and operating your
app use the command line interface to
code build and run your app locally a
common pattern is to create your app
from a developer portal in the IBM cloud
console use the developer tools to
develop locally then push the updates to
your repo and merge to start your
deployment tool chain install the IBM
cloud CLI in two easy steps and if
you're looking for a place where you can
experiment with big ideas and emerging
technologies be sure to check out the
Raj method deployments you can learn how
IBM can help develop apps in your
organization ready to get started
building production-ready apps
[Music]